So now let's look at the whole schematic of a simple charge couple device.
Here I'm basically showing an animation of each and
every layer of a charge couple device.
We are going to basically now peel this back out as an onion, and
look at each one of them separately.
But of course,
point is, light is coming down this way and hitting a variety of layers.
And then, of course, it hits the bottom layer,
where actually the current is stored.
Let's again, look at this by peeling the onion layer by layer.
So the first layer basically has a little bit of an optical flavor.
It's what is referred to as a micro lens.
What in essence it does, it captures the light and
directs it towards the light sensitive areas beneath it.
So when light hits these types of things,
it focuses it down to the next layer so then nothing is lost.
The next layer is referred to as the hot mirror.
This is where some of the simple filtering is done.
So in the case of the film, this saw the example of a UV filter.
Well this is somewhat similar.
Basically it let's visible light pass, but
reflects light in the invisible spectrum.
And basically doesn't pre, it prevents it from hitting the sensors below.
So this simple sort of filtering and prevents the unnecessary light to hit.
Of course, different types of cameras would do different things.
So for example, if you wanted to build a UV camera,
this would not be filtering out the UV light.
In fact it would be amplifying it.
This is what's referred to as a color filter.
Remember light has lots of constituent colors.
Most of the time we try to represent them or
at least capture them in RGB format.
And that's what we're going to try to understand how to do here.
So in essence, the photo diodes that are below it are actually color blind.
They basically want to capture the intensity.
So this is where we kind of start now looking at and separating out the colors.
This is usually referred to as a Bayer Array.
And we'll talk about Bayer Arrays in a bit.
Basically what it does, it takes a color and separates the light into red,
green, and blue.
And, once it's been ordered into red, green, and blue it hits
the photo diodes that are below which are then measured the intensity of it.
Of course, this pattern is unique and knowing this pattern is
essential because it'll tell us how to be able to convert the value from,
in this case, two greens, red and
a blue to figure out what would the value at this point of the image.
So as noted, these are the photo diodes.
This is exactly where the light energy that now actually is hitting each one of
these, is converted to electrons and carries a strong negative charge.
The final layer is the Well, or sometimes referred to as the depletion layer.
This is where electrons are collected and usually there is a processor that
charges the photo diodes with a positive charge, and then of course all
the negative charges basically are stored and collected on this layer.
So in essence, when you're pressing a shutter,
what you're doing is of course opening the shutter.
And also giving a charge to this device so
that can it capture all of these stuff.
In case of a chemical film, all you need to do is open the shutter and
that's when exactly the storage happens.
And of course, when the storage happens, you move the film across.
In this one, all of the stored, captured off, and
we'll talk about that in a bit, too.
So in essence, we peeled this whole onion and
we saw all the details of how light goes all the way and then ends up
as a stored electrical set of values which are then converted to pixels.